un champ de colza jeu morse actuel
transformé en terrain de fouilles
archéologiques
quand j'étais petit j'adorais venir me
balader dans les champs de mes grands
parents car j'aime bien être au vent
terre comme ça et puis il se balader et
en même temps de retrouver plein
d'anciens objets dont j'essaye de
découvrir l'histoire à 16 ans seulement
ce lycéen et passionné d'histoire à
thiers c'est peut-être un morceau de
haches polies qui datent du néolithique
et vu que c'est un éclat on peut savoir
que du coup c'était une tâche dont ils
se sont servis pour abattre les arbres
des connaissances pointues qu'il aime
transmettre à ses amis donc on ne le
connais pas je faisais pas du tout ça je
m'intéressais spécialement quelle
histoire
donc je la prenais les rois tout ça les
empereurs mais grâce à lui j'ai vu une
autre facette de l'histoire un premier
admirateur et ce n'est pas le seul ce
berrichon a voulu rassembler ses
trouvailles celle de sa famille et
d'archéologues pour réaliser une
exposition retraçant l'histoire de
vineuil ce sont des objets qui
proviennent de collections particulières
et privés qui ont été trouvés la
majorité dans à vineuil une centaine de
vestiges comme cette fille bull ou ses
poteries datant pour certaines de
l'époque romaine les visiteurs sont
conquis si on démarre jeunes on peut on
a des chances de de s'approprier des
connaissances sauf à mesure des années
qui passent
je suis vraiment étonné de voir qu'un
jeune fille
s'intéresser voilà à tout ce qui
concerne archéologie les vestiges et
c'est une exposition réussie et pour
maxence luneau une première expérience
professionnelle concluant c'est vraiment
la mission du conservateur de musée du
coup là je vois que justement ça
pourrait vraiment me claire ce métier là
dans la vie plus tard l'exposition se
termine demain et dans quelques jours
déjà maxence retournera sur les bancs du
lycée pour apprendre l'histoire dans les
livres cette fois ci